buenos días mientras avanzan las obras
crece la indignación al conocerse los
rostros de los implicados en este
escándalo desde el dueño de un
restaurante chino pasando por suegras
hermanas de altos funcionarios el
escándalo ha salpicado a la misma
iglesia católica el representante del
vaticano en perú único la girasol y
también recibió la dosis de zinc o farc
de otro lado las autoridades también han
identificado a ocho diplomáticos quienes
estuvieron negociando con la empresa si
no fuera para que la vacuna llegará al
perú y ellos también fueron vacunados el
canciller allan wagner les ha solicitado
su inmediata renuncia